Pete Davidson and Emily radakowski take
their romance Courtside he's got the
height he is obviously women find him
very attractive on Sunday night the two
were spotted at the New York Knicks
Memphis Grizzlies game at Madison Square
Garden marking their first public
appearance since sparking dating rumors
earlier this month in photos shared by
the Knicks Pete and Emily were all
smiles laughing and seemingly enjoying
their night out I've been fortunate
enough to have some great relationships
and you know uh honesty is always really
important the pair hasn't confirmed
their romance but their Courtside
appearance certainly got people talking
in the comments like the Denver Nuggets
account who wondered can you ask them if
it's official the Knicks replied would
but they're busy and the Atlanta Hawks
were all of us writing we need more info
the Knicks responded literally same
earlier this month a source confirmed to
E.T the comedian and model are seeing
each other
explaining Emily and Pete have known
each other for a while because they run
in similar circles quote they've always
had such a good time together and liked
each other and on Monday a separate
source told E.T Pete is really happy
quote he thinks Emily is beautiful smart
chill and down to earth he feels like he
can be himself around her and relax he
seems super Charming he's vulnerable
he's lovely great his fingernail polish
is awesome like he looks good there you
go great all right well I'm sold I'm
gonna have him back on good relationship
with his mother yeah great relationship
with his mother we love it yeah and now
it seems Emily's the latest lady to be
Charmed by Pete following his many
public romances our source added they've
been spending one-on-one time with each
other and things are flirtatious
Pete's romance with Emily comes just
months after his split from Kim
Kardashian Pete is has got to be
literally the best human being I've ever
met like the best heart the two called
it quits after nine months of dating you
just gotta roll with it as for how Kim's
feeling about Pete moving on totally
fine yeah our source says the beauty
Mogul is not bothered quote Kim knows
that things were over between her and
Pete she just wants everyone to live
their best lives and be happy Bible and
the Good Vibes come as no surprise
because the former couple ended on
amicable terms people don't see the
context behind it last month A source
told E.T Kim and Pete have remained
friendly and in contact since they're
split
foreign